[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Hi, there.
And thanks for joining us.
I'm Reto Meier.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
I'm Stephanie Wong.
Many of us are reaching for
hybrid cloud nirvana, which
makes the workplace mobility
between on-premise and cloud
computing ideal for our work.
To help us navigate
through this,
we welcome Chen Goldberg,
Engineering Director
for Google Cloud.
Nice to have you here.
CHEN GOLDBERG: Hi.
Thank you very much
for inviting me.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
Now hybrid cloud is
a common strategy
that businesses
look to modernize,
while still supporting
their current applications.
How does Google Cloud approach
this particular charge?
CHEN GOLDBERG: So
first of all, it's
important to understand why
customers want to modernize
and why they are
looking for that.
And the most important thing is
for them, in order to compete,
they have to increase
their developer agility
and help them to
be more focused.
And they really want
to take advantage
of the amazing capabilities
that are available in the cloud
and using new cloud services.
But they have to make a decision
and a choice because they
cannot modernize
everything at once.
That's one of their concerns.
The second thing
is that they also
have concerns from
regulations that requires
them to stay on premises.
So from their perspective,
it is a reality
that hybrid is here
to stay and they
have to choose a hybrid
strategy in order
to modernize and
advance their business.
For us at Google
Cloud, we understand
that we need to support our
customers in their journey.
OK?
And our goal is to
make sure that we
help them reduce
the risk, instead
of increasing the risk when
going through this journey.
And risk are coming
in different levels.
For example, not
fragmenting your talent
and allowing to create
a consistent experience
everywhere, and also really
leveraging the existing assets
you have today.
So not asking them to buy
new hardware, for example,
but really blending in to
their existing environment.
STEPHANIE WONG: And how
does this truly differ
from other hybrid offerings?
CHEN GOLDBERG: Google puts the
user at first, in the center.
And we understand
that our customers
appreciate to have choice.
They want to be able
to choose where they're
going to deploy their workloads,
what kind of tools, resources
to use.
And our goal is to make that
possible, while reducing risk.
We do it by building our
platform based on open source
technologies, which are ensuring
that their work is portable
and we are not locking them in.
And we're also now approaching
multi-cloud strategically
and giving consistent experience
wherever customers choose
to deploy their workloads.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
That's amazing.
What components make up Anthos?
And how do those
components work together
to provide a really integrated
approach for our customers?
CHEN GOLDBERG: So Anthos
is a premiere platform
managed by Google.
In the foundation,
in the core of it,
we are using open
source technologies
originated by Google, like
Kubernetes, Istio, and Knative.
But this is not sufficient
for our customer
to manage their trigenious
environments they have.
On top of that, we are building
a multi-cloud, multi-cluster
control plane that lets
our customers connect
to all of their environments
and manage them in a [INAUDIBLE]
through a single pane of glass.
We also give them tools to
manage policies and control
in all of those environments.
But not everything
is containerized.
And this is also about investing
with what they have today.
So on top of that, we are
creating a service management
platform, which allows them
to connect all those services,
regardless of what
compute there is.
And on top of everything we
have an awesome marketplace
that allows us to
provide, both first party
and third party applications
available in all
of those environments.
STEPHANIE WONG: So
you just mentioned
investing in what our customers
are already using today.
How can Anthos be used to
help them modernize in place?
CHEN GOLDBERG: So what we
hear from our customers,
that when they come and they
want to use new cloud services,
they have first to qualify and
make sure that the cloud meets
their bar, right?
Let's say they want to
use BigQuery or even GKE,
they need to go through the
specific process, usually
manual process, to
make sure they can
let their developers use it.
With GKE On-Prem they don't
need to go through that process
because we bring this technology
into their data center
and they know it meets the bar.
So that's actually the fastest
way for them to innovate.
RETO MEIER: That's great.
What about conflict
management with Anthos?
How can you write multi-cluster
policies right out of the box?
CHEN GOLDBERG: So
that's a great question.
I think that the number
one concern that CEOs have
is how they manage risk
and, specifically, how can
they make sure
that they know who
access what resources
and making sure
that they know what policies
are applied everywhere.
And when you have more
and more environments
you have to build
more and more tools
and have more
people manage that.
So Anthos Config
Management allows
you to manage those policies
from a centralized place.
And even if by accident
or by a malicious user,
someone is trying to
break that policy,
automatically we will
apply that policy
and bring that environment
back to be compliant.
RETO MEIER: Great.
STEPHANIE WONG: So more
environments, more tools.
Can you elaborate
on what we're doing
to users the
visibility they need,
so that they can
see what's happening
across all these environments?
CHEN GOLDBERG: Yes.
So we are leveraging
open APIs, which
allows us to actually integrate
with every environment,
wherever the user chooses.
And we are creating
tools, centralized tools,
in the control plane that
gives you signals or monitoring
data from all of
those environments
in a consistent way.
And we're also leveraging
things like Knative.
We just announced
Cloud Run as beta
to give a simple and effective
user experience for developers,
again to deploy to all
of those environments.
So when I think
about it, it's not
about portability of
workloads, but it's actually
about portability of skills.
Can my developers, can
my service operators
use the same set of tools,
regardless of which environment
they want to use?
And by leveraging open
source technologies,
this is actually possible.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
That's fantastic.
I'm curious, how are
customers using Anthos today?
And what are some of the
more interesting use cases
that you may have come across?
CHEN GOLDBERG: I'm smiling
because, ever since we've
announced back that it was
CSP eight months ago as alpha,
we've seen an overwhelming
excitement with our customers.
Over 1,000 customers showed
interest, just during Next,
to try out CSV Anthos.
And we see a different
type of use cases.
So I would say for
someone like HSBC,
they were excited to give
their developers platform,
a modern platform,
without having
to go through all
the qualification
and making sure that the new
environment meets the bar.
So they're doing both.
But they know that for
some of their workloads
they will have to stay On-Prem.
And we see other customers,
like Kohl's for example,
that are looking to
innovate, both On-Prem
and in the cloud and create
a consistent environment.
And maybe talking about
a customer like KeyBank.
OK?
So they're really excited
about the agility.
So really leveraging new
tools and making sure they
can deploy quickly in
other environments.
So different customers
see different use cases
to begin with, but they're all
very excited, by both agility
and reducing risk.
RETO MEIER: Thanks,
Chen, for walking us
through the
possibilities of Anthos.
CHEN GOLDBERG: Thank
you for having me.
RETO MEIER: Of course.
[MUSIC PLAYING]